all right so I'm going to be talking
about a package that we made actually a
couple packages we made for using Bert
in our Bert I'm gonna explain what that
is but that's the Google natural
language processing framework and it's
really cool all right
first I want to acknowledge sorry I want
to acknowledge Jonathan brat who did
really most of the work on the packages
he couldn't be here today unfortunately
but his github will be featured very
prominently throughout this he's a
colleague of mine at macmillan learning
where we are both data scientists all
right and so if you want to follow along
you can go to this randomly generated
URL that bitly put together that will
take you to a tweet which you can like
and retweet and reply to and then you
can click through to go to my go to my
slide day so yeah I'm gonna today be
doing a really brief overview of
transfer learning because that's what
Bert brings to natural language
processing then I'm going to talk a
little bit about Bert I'm going to talk
about the two packages that we made to
use Bert in our and then we're gonna see
how you can kind of see how Bert thinks
sort of using looking at attention and
at the layer outputs and all of this
hopefully will make more sense by the
end of the talk alright so first
transfer learning a key example of this
was about five years ago people were
making models to classify the image net
image set it's like 14 15 million images
tagged to like 20,000 categories and it
got to a point or it is very much to a
point where we can see that on the early
layers of these these neural nets you
get just simple feature extra
actors so here we can see that it's an
edge detector it can see light to dark
or dark to light edges and then those
add things like that add up together
where you start getting things like a
face detector or a text detector in
later layers I've got a link to this in
the slide deck if you go to the github
and the video that they made about this
is just amazing it's really mind-blowing
how they were able to like really kind
of explain how this neural net is doing
image classification classification and
an important thing here is no one
trained it to detect faces or to detect
text for example that one of the
categories was bookcases and so in order
to find bookcases it figured out so to
speak that it needs to be able to find
text to find a book to find a bookcase
and so it just learned these deeper
layers we had we've had kind of transfer
learning in natural language processing
for a while now in the form of word
embeddings word Tyvek and glove are two
examples of that and the famous case
that really I people should find other
ones because of if only this works
that's not that impressive but if you
take the vector for King you subtract
the vector for man you add the vector
for woman the closest word is Queen
which is pretty cool you can start doing
math with language the problem with that
is each word has one embedding so if you
have these two sentences
I saw the branch on the bank versus I
saw the branch of the bank those two
sentences like every word in those is
going to have almost exactly the same
well every word except on and of will
have exactly the same embedding but
branch in the first sentence means a
stick and Bank on the first sentence
means the edge of a river
whereas branch in the second sentence is
a subset of a bank which is you know a
building
so last year there were a whole bunch of
advancements in NLP doing more kind of
sentence level embedding and it
culminated in October of last year with
Bert
that stands for bi-directional encoder
representations from transformers we're
gonna look at what transformers are a
little bit and hopefully it'll kind of
make sense the bi-directional part is
just they're looking at both ends of the
sentence they'll take they'll mask a
word in the middle and then use the
words before it and after it to figure
out what that word was which obviously
that's how language actually works is
the whole sentence matters so that was a
good advancement this was trained with a
very large corpus they used Wikipedia
and Google books like all of the books
that they've scanned and the cool thing
about this is it is transferable you can
put in a sentence and extract some
features and use them for your own model
you just take off their their
classification tasks at the end put on
your own and you can you can do some
cool things and to do that in our we
have this package are Bert it's
available on github with you can use dev
tools to install it right now it's an
implementation of Bert in our right now
you can use it for that feature
extraction where you just pull out you
give it a sentence or tons of sentences
and for each sentence it gives you a
vector to represent that sentence so you
can do that right now we're working
right now on making it work for fine
tuning where you could put your own
neural net piece on the end of it and
let it kind of relax and find new
features that will probably be a future
talk in January all right and then we
also made this our Bert vis this has
basically two functions visualized
attention and display PCA we're going to
be looking at that because those two
functions the reason we made this
package is it lets you see how bird is
thinking
which again will make more sense in a
second so all right
attention the code on the left here
shows just it's actually it's a little
aspirational it'll work this way next
week if you really want to if you want
to use it today go look at the code for
my slides and you can see the extra
arguments that are in there but this is
how it'll work next week so but it's
almost this simple it's just simpler or
it's a little bit more complicated
inside but you tell it what model you're
going to use you give it a sentence tell
it what layers you care about in the
Bert base there are twelve layers and
you tell it you want attention and it
will pull off the attention send that
through our Bert vis and it creates this
HTML widget which I am going to
hopefully yes all right so what we're
looking at here is again this particular
pre-trained Bert model has 12 layers so
we can go through and look at different
layers this drop-down isn't important
for most tasks but that's if you feed it
two sentences at a time it can it can
compare across the sentences but we're
just gonna look at one sentence versus
itself and then within each layer what
the transformer is is it has these heads
we're gonna just focus on one head right
now in this particular head it does some
math and it decides what other words in
the sentence should each token pay
attention to this CLS token is just a
it's class class is what it stands for
and it's just like an overall token for
the whole sentence but each word in the
sentence is given like a weight of how
much each how much it should pay
attention to each other word and then it
uses that weight to update its own
vector and yet as you go through the
layers the vectors change we're gonna
see how that comes out Oh an important
thing here is
surprisingly the vocabulary Bert uses
isn't that good because it can't be a
good vocabulary if it doesn't know the
word taco so it breaks it down into taw
and coasts but as it goes through the
layers its able to figure out that those
go together and that they mean something
important
clearly alright so something interesting
we'll look at it here and then we're
gonna look at it for the other sentence
is just a few layers in you get
something that's kind of like the edge
detectors where it doesn't look like
much here but it's just hey pay
attention to the next word the next word
might matter use the weight from that
and so each of these words so other than
the weird tokens at the beginning and an
end they're just looking at the next
token and let's go back alright so if we
look at some more complicated sentences
we've got the chicken didn't cross the
road because it was too tired the
chicken didn't cross the road because it
was too wide the dog fetched the ball it
was excited and the dog fetched the ball
it was blue obviously the last word in
each of those sentences changes what it
means within that sentence as a human we
can read this and say oh yeah it's the
chicken it's the road it's the dog it's
the ball and the cool thing is well I'm
sorry I'm not getting the cool thing yet
so across all those sentences that layer
three head one is doing the same thing
it's saying hey look at the next word
most of the point of this is just to see
that a head like has a function a head
is doing something if we look at layer 9
head 5 it
it's a pronoun resolution head and this
is kind of equivalent equivalent to that
face detector no one told this thing to
learn to find pronouns just in order to
understand language that was something
that had to train and so
we've got it chicken if we look it's it
Road it dog and it ball now it's a
little some of them are a little
distributed it's not a hundred percent
sure but that's really cool like it's it
really is kind of understanding the
language so the net the other thing all
those heads add up on each of those
layers to give us an output for that
layer to demonstrate this I did a poll
online where I just asked people to
submit sentences one sentence about the
about learning using the word train as
in teach and then another sentence about
travel using the word train as in the
vehicle I've got some code there again
so it's just you know we can extract the
features we're saying we want the output
here we're gonna start at layer zero
which is just the input embeddings that
it gives before it does any any travel
through the neural network and then I
tie those labels back on to our the the
labels back to the output and so this is
just looking at one example of each of
the words that people used so they use
train down here trains trained and
training and at layer zero
that's all it knows is it just has one
thing for each word one one point when
we add all the other ones there's a
little bit of wiggle on them because it
also takes the position within the
sentence in the context but for the most
part you know these are all train these
are all trains these are all trained and
these are all training and here the
green means that it's teach and the
black means that it's a locomotive and
so as we step through the layers we can
see that it actually does start to
separate those by meaning except for
this one
wait what what's going on with that one
and when I first made this it's like
I'll crap I'm gonna have to find
something else to use for my demo
because that I want to show it actually
working today I went and looked up the
sentence and again this was gathered
from random people on the internet so
that wasn't at a sentence about a
locomotive it's not really even a
sentence but it was classified into
teach because it's more teach than it is
vehicle all right so we have a lot to do
Arbor is usable now but it can be a lot
better we like I said some of this is
aspirational already that I wanted to
show it show how easy it's gonna be in
about a week it's already pretty easy
I've used it to build a couple of models
it works really insanely well that just
pulling out those features and then
using those within XG boost and it can
do classification really well our goal
is to have it up on cran by the end of
this year which is about a month away so
we're pushing hard on that and towards
that we are right now it works with
tensorflow 1.13
in in that range we're gonna upgrade it
to tensorflow 2.0 which just came out
that's in testing right now and actually
Jonathan is back in Austin working on
that right now the other thing we want
to do is we basically copied this code
from the Google code the Google Python
code it's under the hood it's got a lot
of weird things that it's doing and on
the front end it's just it's not
friendly so we're we're working on that
making it more friendly and then if
you've worked with tidy models we're
gonna put a recipe step in there to make
extracting those features super easy so
you can just pull out the features of
your sentences and use them within a
model we will have a poster at our
studio account in January and I
encourage everyone to go to bit ly /r
Bert poster
and give us ideas of what you would like
to see on that poster
we might just use the submissions of
ideas in our poster because that's text
that we could parse but whatever you
might have we don't know yet we're not
sure what we're gonna show there's lots
of cool things that we could do all
right you can contact me so you might be
shocked to hear that I'm on Twitter a
lot I'm at John the geek that's Jo n you
can go there maybe like and reply and
retweet some things you can find our
packages on github at Jonathan Brett's
github slash our Bert and slash our Bert
vis again those are usable right now and
every you can just watch them every day
they get a little better you can find my
github I've got well my forks of these
but I've also got some other stuff there
you can also find me on the r4d s online
learning community our Ferdie esta
online most Saturdays I host an office
hour there for just any random are
questions you might have
not this week and actually not next week
but most Saturdays and I also have a
podcast tidy Tuesday calm hopefully if
he's still in the area
I'm gonna be interviewing David Robinson
and that'll be up on Tuesday but
normally it's a it's a podcast about
visualization which is hard to do
sometimes but I think I do okay and I
managed to talk very quickly and so I'm
gonna give you back a few minutes
[Applause]